okay this week's new rules the South
Dakota Department of Public Safety can
say this ad campaign doesn't mean stop
masturbating yeah but then they have to
say what it does mean and tell me how
else am I supposed to stay awake when I
Drive through South Dakota knurl stop
trying to create controversy when a
biopic doesn't tell the whole story
it's a movie not a murder confession but
that's the knock against three of this
year's Oscar contenders Selma unbroken
and Foxcatcher
they left things out you know what you
get when you don't leave things out 19
hours of The Hobbit it's a movie if I
want to hear every single pointless
soul-crushing detail of a stranger's
life I'll follow them on Instagram new
role before fashionable Christians pay
you're way ahead of me for fashionable
Christians pay $800 for a cross from Tom
Ford they might want to take another
look up close it's less Jesus and more
Saint Peter also if you're still
shopping online for nice Christian
jewelry do not Google pearl necklace
just tell tell the person sitting next
new rule now that Amazon has signed
Woody Allen to write and direct his
first TV series it must be called How I
Met Your Daughter new rule new role this
new British furniture collection
designed to look feel and smell like
human skin must be made immediately
available in the United States because
why just sit on a conventional fabric
chair when you can feel like you're
being cradled in the crack of a fat
guy's ass okay yes just what every
American wife needs another motionless
doughy lump plopped down in front of the
TV